well let's go back to our breaking news
out of Algeria where a military chief
ahmed guides sally has died of a heart
attack at the age of 80 ammo boubakr is
a research fellow at the European
Council on Foreign Relations she joins
us on skype from Algiers a warm welcome
to you to the program and just explain
for us how significant is the death of
guide Saleh that is crucial is going to
shift any kind of scenario that was
produced a plane being on the side of
the army of course but also being on the
new president's ID Boone who has been
placed at the head of the country by
guide Sarah himself so a lot of things
have going to change but other a lot of
things may be negotiated
but above all it could be a historic
opportunity for the army to make
succession mechanisms transparent and
negotiated a once just explain if you
will for our viewers a little bit more
of the context and the timing of his
death because it comes a time when
there's been a very turbulent
transitional period which he was key to
making progress within right yes
actually gates hour came at the head of
the army in 2004 he was appointed at
this position by a Budokai himself just
at the very beginning of his second
mandate and doing so good Luke I wanted
to get rid of the old army generals that
had managed the civil wars so we used to
call them in algae and history do short
lists because they are they have been
responsible for the cook of shortly our
January 2192 so again that was probably
an opportunity to to rebalance hates his
influence about the army and he remained
quite quite loyal to bouteflika until
the Herrick started and when the hillock
started actually gain so that shifted
his allegiance to bouteflika saying that
we need to sacrifice
okay and she turn the page and have a
new regime and and and real guy and he
his circles in jail that's what that
what he did so gates are had been
central in rearranging or reorganizing
the system the relook system that is
currently in place in algeria i'm
Abubakr their research fellow the
European Council on Foreign Relations
thank you very much for your thoughts